welcome back I am smiling like a chesher
cat because we are teaming up all season
long with our wonderful Partners LG for
a very special
announcement and my Rossy Ross Matthews
has the
411 yeah that's right the LG wonderbox
showcas is an annual digital art
competition that provides College art
students in opportunity to have their
work displayed on a grand stage I'm
talking LG's Time Square billboard I
know and they win LG products along with
a cash prize this year's theme focused
on the concept of Life's good and
promoting the power of optimism and
creativity so students across the
country signed up to compete and we have
the three finalists with us today right
here but someone's going to win here and
a team of LG judges have voted and we're
about to announce the winners right now
on our show
okay coming in third place receiving
$5,000 is life path by Luke fabricator
Julian doot and Sam Miller
congratulations the
art that is so cool it's like a Rube
Goldberg yeah exactly oh I totally get
it it's so fun and and it is optimistic
what was your like uh inspiration the
ball sort of goes through this like
track that like goes ups and downs like
the ups and downs of life you know but
it keeps a smile the whole time cuz
that's what life is about you know it's
always
like God okay coming in second place our
runner up receiving $10,000 is Splendid
by JJ and Jenny
Jun thank you what was your guys'
concept behind this actually we just uh
brought that product all in that is like
a really like colorful and like a
childish like a rubber ducky in Lincoln
Log Tedd that makes like a hour makes me
happy so just we I know why does
everything have to get so serious right
well I think that might mean we have the
actual winner not the finalist that
means our first place winner is peace is
within by arv tavari you're going home
with
$25,000
okay what was your inspiration behind
this it's the little things in life just
like going out doors being in nature
being with people you love so the art
work's like a reflection on how I view
life you got wow
right I just want to say like I think
there's a real depth to this competition
you know LG it stands for Life's good
and we have to keep that hope alive
because we all need that juice
that life is good I love what you all
made congratulations thank you to our
partner at LG cuz Life's good and there
is goodness in the world and that is the
art you put out into the world and we
make it all for you so just take it with
you thank you for
[Music]
watching